make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are covering the conclusion
to spawn on a spawn Armageddon this is
the very last thing and here's my
question for you guys those of you guys
who are really knowledgeable about spawn
where should we go from here
you guys were the ones who told me to
cover spawn Armageddon and you guys
proved to be right so I'm deferring to
you guys again where did we jump to
after this what do you think that we
should cover but any event with the main
Armageddon battle having happened right
the end of God and Satan and that kind
of a thing them them doing you know
whatever the case is one of the things
to understand now is that we are
basically on an alternate earth is
really kind of how this works right it's
not really the recreated earth earth as
it originally existed has been
essentially devoid of all life has been
destroyed and God and Satan are fighting
on that world for evermore at this point
what we do is we switch to kind of this
this new earth as we created by spawn
and Al Simmons trying to return home now
if you guys recall in the last video
initially the mother of creation tried
to stop it but Al Simmons blew the
mother of creation off and just kind of
continued towards the house at which
point Al Simmons has stopped deadness
tracks and the reason why is because the
mother of creation basically says
there's something that you have to see
in you before you go in here before you
reveal yourself to them there's
something that you need to know and so
what what the mother of creation does is
kind of remove spawn from his physical
form and give him somewhat of like an
astral form but the initial kind of
conversation going on between the
Simmons family with Terry granny with
cyan with that with Wanda is they're
really kind of recovering from
everything right now remember a lot of
what happened Wanda and and Terry don't
really recall granny remembers all of it
right because she died and she went to
heaven then found out that God wasn't
really God as she believed him to be and
all that kind of stuff if you guys want
you guys want to get caught up make sure
you check the the description for the
playlist of spawn to get all the stuff
right we're like five videos in there so
it's not super complex or anything a
good way to kind of cope with the
quarantine but nonetheless you know for
her first lie and she remembers a great
deal of it and it's one of these things
where she basically says I don't want to
refer to like you know spawn or to - Al
Simmons ask the sad man anymore I'm
gonna call an Al because that's his name
as well it's kind of a cool theme
because granny kind of talked about
what's going on and it's got you know
from from Wanda and Terry that was kind
of okay you need to go to sleep that
kind of a thing it's not really
dismissive so much is this kind of the
belief that like granny's off her rocker
and then you start to get into the meat
and potatoes and the worst thing that
Swann ever did and what this does is it
initially picks up with Terry
wandah going into the bedroom and then
of course Wanda initially tries to kind
of initiate sexy time and Terry's not
really receptive to it and the reason
why is because I guess really is it's
one of these things were their romantic
life their love life is almost
non-existent and the reason for this is
because Terry has like a lot of issues
that he's struggling with at the moment
one of the things we kind of find out
here is that with Al Simmons returned
Terry's been struggling with this right
because it's not enough that al Simmons
came back Al Simmons came back and then
basically saved all of existence right
so it's like if you were dating a girl
and then she was like well you know me
and my ex broke up and then you meet her
ex and her ex turns out to be Superman
right like that's kind of what this is
to a degree and and and Terry is in a
lot of ways kind of feeling emasculated
by that this is also compounded by the
fact that when he sort of lashes out
wanted responses you know I love you
with all my heart you know that's that's
never gonna go away I'm always going to
love Al Simmons because he was a man
that I was married to but you're who I'm
with now suddenly we find out that what
Terry's been doing has been snooping and
in essentially Wanda is kind of kept
this box of artifacts there's this kind
of box of things that belong to Al
Simmons right pictures love letters
different things like that and she
looked at them almost every single day
she kind of kisses them and almost seems
you know this is from Terry's
perspective
she misses Al Simmons so much and can't
really let go and so the way that Terry
sees this is really from the perspective
of Wanda is still in love with Al
Simmons and that if Al Simmons comes
back right now immediately Terry's gonna
get the boot right even goes as far as
to say you've been a great friend you
helped me through some tough times but
you got to go cuz my man's back that's
kind of how he views all of this and
this is when we really get we get the
bean spilled on everything because when
one learns that Terry was snooping she's
like so what are you gonna do next are
you gonna hit me and his responses god
no why would I ever do that and she said
because Al Simmons did and that's when
you really learn the truth of what else
and that's not the worst thing he did
right but that's when you learned the
truth about Al Simmons when we look at
the character of spawn we always saw him
as just a guy who was married to a great
woman and he potentially had a great
life and then he was betrayed by his
friend Jason when his boss Jason went
and then ended up becoming a hell spawn
he could never go back home right he
seemed like a character who was in a
tragic situation a great guy in an
incredibly tragic scenario it is
anything but that what we end up
learning is the first time that that Al
Simmons hit Wanda was when they were at
a party they had both been drinking they
came back and Al Simmons just always
kind of had this thing for his boss
right he always
duk-soo if Jason when he always idolized
him and when Wanda wanted to initiate
like like you know an intimate moment
what she wanted to have sex Alstom and
just kind of said no I'm not really
interested in that and then she said
well then let's get your boss and then
we can do a threesome and maybe it'll
get some wood in your pecker right and
where she was joking he lashes out and
hits her following that it happened at
different points in time and for
different reasons right sometimes he
choked her sometimes he backhanded her
sometimes he hit her with a closed fist
and it was one of these things where she
she goes as far as to say she never
really understood why you know how it is
that like women in abusive relationships
don't just leave right like why don't
they just walk away what's so hard about
that like your man hits you you leave
it's not rocket science
and that's how she viewed it right like
how come I can't do that the reality was
she was in love with him you know and if
you really look into the psychology of
that there's a lot of women who give a
lot of different reasons for why that
happens right they feel like they can't
do anything on their own I've kind of
been made to feel like like they're
inferior they can't live without that
person whatever the case happens to be
but there's a lot of psychological
effects that go into abusive
relationships and that's one of the
things that happened here Al Simmons
would buy her like a puppy or something
along those lines but the reality of
this is that Wanda looked at Al and
realized that that she was second best
that the love of his life was war it was
conflict it was fighting things and
killing people that's the way it was
right that's the thing that he cared
about the most and when she initially
sat down and sort of having this
conversation where I mean when she's
talking to Terry one of the things she
says is there was a point where she
became pregnant and Al Simmons watching
all this go down didn't know but he had
no idea that that Wanda was pregnant and
essentially you know it's kind of like
we tried so many times it wasn't really
possible that Wanda had essentially gone
off the pill she had been on birth
control all this time and Al Simmons
didn't know and so finally she goes off
birth control and then basically decides
I want to get pregnant with this guy
right and so following that what this
does is it turns it to a thing where she
starts talking to him about that I went
off the pill I'm pregnant now you know
that kind of a thing and initially he's
kind of upset about the fact that she
made that choice without telling him but
what he basically says is like there's a
world out there there's a dark and a
cruel and a horrible world and like if
my job is the man on the wall to keep it
at bay I'm the only one that can keep
this world safe I'm the one that has to
do these things you know so on and so
forth but it's this idea that like only
he can protect the world right only he
can keep everything safe right he's the
only guy capable of doing that and that
the reality of him is that there are two
sides to Al Simmons
there's the family man
Al Simmons then there's just the
murderous flipping a switch doing
whatever you need to do and removing the
emotion from the equation kind of guy
and so the result of this is that he
begins to kind of lash out you know for
a moment when he looks at her you know
she says he got this look they looked at
people he's killed have probably seen on
his face for the last time what he does
is he pushes her in the gut and then
basically forces her to miscarry and
that's the worst things al sim and
that's the worst thing I'll Simmons did
is he basically hit his wife she
miscarried and he killed his own baby
and it's extreme right it's it's insane
because it takes everything about Al
Simmons that we knew and it totally
flips it on its head but it totally
changes everything up because he's no
longer this guy who was just a really
great guy in a bad situation
Al Simmons was a terrible human being
and that's one of these things where he
doesn't believe any of what he's hearing
the whole idea behind Wanda was that
when he went on his final mission where
he ended up dying of course he didn't
know that he was gonna die neither did
she
the intention was that when he came back
she was gonna leave him she was gonna
she was gonna walk away she's gonna be
like we're done divorce him and then
basically end up end up leaving but such
as it was Al Simmons ended up being
killed and then basically became spawn
which kind of solved the solve the
equation for her finding Terry what's
exactly what she needed right she needed
a great man she needed a man that she
could kind of expose the worst parts of
herself to and then still be accepted
right not be rebuked that's what she
needed was just a great man and so
following that Al Simmons basically
takes off and the mother of creation
basically verifies all of this and says
this was all true these are all memories
that you suppress everything that you
heard from Wanda is true I haven't
manipulated reality I haven't changed
anything I didn't trick you into hearing
something that wasn't actually being
said that's true like this is your
history this is your past you're not the
man you think you are when you died and
then when you went to hell and you
encounter mal Bhoja you chose to become
a hell spawn because subconsciously you
believed that you deserve to be punished
for what it was that you done that's why
you chose to become spawn and so at the
end of the day when spawns like well
then kill me like kill me and let this
be done the response to the mother of
creation is no this is your penance this
is the price you pay for the things that
you've done
you have to redeem yourself now you are
basically just kind of out there spawn
is more or less in purgatory now right
that's kind of how he is he's not really
in hell but he's not really in heaven he
has to redeem himself and prove that
he's a good guy in order to be able to
get into heaven or whatever it is the
actual heaven that kind of exists out
there were those who are good people go
when they die
presumably the realm of the mother of
creation we're not really sure but
basically the the mother chrétien tells
spawn it's now time for you to go back
home when spawn asked where that is the
mother of creation says you know where
that is right back down to the alleys
again it's amazing like it's it's crazy
but is it this is the darkest thing the
spawn ever did spawn killed his own kid
right he was so obsessed with the idea
of the life that he saw for him so I
guess the life that he'd kind of went
after violence death destruction that it
consumed him in its entirety and
basically cost him his life and the life
of his child so with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comments
explain and make sure you guys have the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]